wow I can't believe it this new AI can
look at a real tennis player and put
them in a computer game where we can
play with them this looks absolutely
amazing and doing this the hard way has
so far been absolutely impossible but
what about the easy way exciting as this
may seem perhaps there is nothing new
here you see we can already do something
like this through motion capture what is
that well you put a human in a studio
attach these little balls to them and
record their motion then transfer this
motion to a virtual character however
this paper has an incredible twist and
that twist is that this can do the same
but without the balls no cameras
gyroscopes or any additional Machinery
is required just the raw video feed and
the learning happens from that that
sounds incredible but how dear fellow
Scholars this is 2minute papers with Dr
Caro well there are previous works that
try to do something similar but the
Precision of these motions was almost
never satisfactory especially for tennis
where almost hitting a ball is not
nearly good enough and I am very proud
to say that all three of these papers
have been chased here on two minute
papers before but this new technique
this one can do it even better first we
give it the raw video feed of the
players and then it will try to estimate
their motion so are we done well
unfortunately not not even close look
the motion is still way too jerky and
imprecise to be used in practice it is
also full of artifacts so what now well
now comes the magic here a computer
simulation is built that tries to
reproduce this motion but this one
cannot be jerky because it is within a
video game where the laws of physics are
intact in reality people don't move like
that and with this simulation H this is
looking so much better from now on we
can take a Target position that we start
from and simulate many many motion types
then we grab a controller and perform
these serves Top Spin Back Spin hits
slices you name it and they look
absolutely incredible yes I hear you
asking caroy are you sure that this is a
simulation well if you look here here is
the proof yes simulations today are
getting so Advanced that we need to see
these 3D models to be absolutely sure
that this is in indeed a computer
simulation wow and it gets better here
is the interesting part this is not just
a copying machine although just copying
the motion from these videos would also
be quite a feat given the occlusions and
Tiny But super important wrist motions
that are really hard to see from the
footage but with this system we can even
highlight the region where we would like
to hit the ball and the Motions will be
syn sized accordingly we can run the
same simulation with a number of
different Target locations and all of
the synthesiz Motions will be believable
and accurate loving it or we can also
ask the player to hit the ball from the
same point from different starting
positions and it will work not only for
the easier cases but in more difficult
scenarios too where you can barely catch
that ball so good and now hold on to
your papers fellow Scholars because it
can not only do all this but it can even
learn the individual style of famous
tennis players right and left-handed
players work too and it can simulate a
one or two-handed backhand shot
depending on the style of the player at
hand and if that is possible at all it
gets even better if we can simulate one
virtual human why not make a game by
simulating two playing against each
other I have to say if I look closely I
can still see that this is a simulation
but if you squint a little it's easy to
think that this is real footage that is
an incredible achievement both in the
graphics and in the animation
departments Bravo and styles are
particularly interesting here because if
it would have only one style two players
playing the same St style would not look
nearly as interesting as this footage
with one left and one right-handed
player what I particularly like is that
there is barely any foot sliding a
problem that you see in almost every
single Paper in this area they usually
compete on how little foot sliding there
is no foot sliding at all is almost
unheard of wow also almost none of the
Jitters from the original motions are
there in this footage the foot sliding
here is less than an inch and the Jitter
is almost non-existent all gone and if
we remove just one small part of this
new proposed system things can go really
bad for instance if the rest motions are
captured with just a bit of inaccuracy
the Heats will go completely wrong you
have to get everything nearly perfectly
for this to work and the scientists
absolutely nailed it so how how many
hundreds of hours did the AI had to sft
through to learn all this well it was
not in the order of hundreds of hours
but get this only 4 and a half hours of
video footage goodness I don't even know
what to say when using the four system
the heat rates can reach up to 100%
which sounds almost impossible to me
they absolutely knocked this out of the
court with this paper and thus it was
published at sigraph perhaps the most
prestigious conference in computer
Graphics in my view it is like winning
the Olympic gold medal of computer
Graphics research and I have to say it
is very welld deserved Bravo this might
be the future of video games experiment
tracking model evaluation and production
monitoring for your deep learning
projects and llm apps this is what
weights and biases does and it is the
the best everyone is using it try it out
now at wb. me/ papers or click the link
in the description below